Are we doing this?
Yep.
Today, we're taking one of the
most popular drinks in America,
a Starbucks Latte,
and seeing what happens
if we dry it out completely.
[Music]
Hey guys, I'm Nate.
Calli.
I'm Calli.
We've got another fun
experiment for you today.
We've dehydrated a
few things before,
and today, we are taking
on a very popular drink.
So today, we've got
a Starbucks latte,
and we're going to see
what happens if we dry it out.
It's a simple idea.
We're going to pour the entire
contents of one Starbucks latte
into our dehydrator,
let it dry out for as
many days as it takes,
and then see what's left.
We've got our
Dehydro-tron 5,000.
We've got our latte.
Let's learn what happens.
Calli, stop drinking it.
No!
Calli is going to be our expert
on what this tasted like,
and you'll probably get
to taste the dried-up bits too.
[Music]
That would be coffee
with milk in it, right?
Yeah, steam pressed.
Steam pressed coffee
with milk in it.
[Music]
Here it goes.
These videos are
no way sponsored
or endorsed by Starbucks.
I'll plug everything in.
There you go.
It's alive.
All right, we've got
this dehydrating.
It's probably take a couple
of days to really dry out of the way.
What do you think
is going to happen?
How dry is the question?
So we've done soda,
and that ended up
just being like a goo.
Like he was like
a really thick syrup,
like molasses consistency.
Then we did milk,
and that like just
completely flaked.
We were able to put
that in a blender
and just turn it into dust.
I'm hoping we get sort
of like a the same thing,
a powdery consistency?
Maybe something that's almost
something that we can break.
But that's kind of what I'm
thinking this going to happen.
So maybe we've got one
that will dry out completely
and be like flaky and dry,
but even just with
the chocolate milk that we did,
that had just milk
and powdered chocolate,
and that still ended up
being just a little bit
more gummy and flexible
than the plain milk.
So I'm not sure
how it's going to end up.
We'll see.
Let's give it a couple days.
Guys, it's now been a few days,
and we have led this lot
a dry out, like dry.
Now, it's time to see
what's happened to it.
She's very disappointed.
All right, pull that tray out.
What even happened?
What?
That-- Okay.
So I think we are both wrong.
You said it was going
to be like crumbly.
I thought it
would be powderized,
but I'm gonna--
It's just like a sheet.
What is this?
Wait...
I regret everything.
It's not good.
Hmm.
Oh, and it certainly
smells very strongly.
It actually weirdly
didn't smell that strong
while it was drying out.
I thought it was.
I thought I was going to like
make the whole house smell
strongly of coffee.
It was pretty mild.
I barely noticed it honestly.
But now, as we're
like breaking it,
I'm smelling a lot more.
See how much this
we can break out,
and fit into our mortar
and pestle here.
Have yourself a
very crispy Christmas.
All right.
So especially compared
to the soda,
this is just flaking right off.
Like yes, there
were sugar in this,
but I think the difference is
probably what, corn syrup?
Okay, that's interesting.
Around the sides
where it's a little bit thicker,
it's still kind
of a weird gummy,
less crackly consistency.
So that is pretty much
what we saw with the milk
and the chocolate milk,
is that it was too thick,
it didn't dehydrate 100%,
and it didn't have quite
the same crumbliness.
[Music]
Nope, still tastes awful.
All right, pretty well grinded?
Ground?
Groundeded.
Pretty well groundeded.
All right, so you're the expert,
and you said this
does not taste good.
It does not taste like a latte.
It doesn't smell like a latte.
So I don't drink coffee,
but I do usually like
the smell of coffee.
This does not really
smell like coffee.
It smells like the coffee
that you leave in the coffee pot
in the office for like
a day on accident.
Gross.
Yeah.
We've got our same cup.
We've got some hot water.
We're going to see if we can turn
this powdered Starbucks back
into regular Starbucks.
Hot water.
This was a 16-ounce latte.
I'm gonna fill up just
a little bit in here.
Let's start with that.
[Music]
It's back to
smelling like coffee.
That looks pretty
much just the same.
So there's a very distinct smell
to Starbucks Coffee.
Anybody who has ever been
in two different coffee shops
would know it.
How would you describe that?
To me, that smells like coffee,
and again, I'm not an expert
by any means,
but like it does actually
smell like coffee,
instead of like burnt hotdog?
I don't know what
it smells like before.
It was not pleasant.
Starbucks is known for having
more of a bitter flavor.
Okay, so I didn't
drink that much,
because they did have
my own latte that morning.
So...
That's less water
than was probably in it when we
poured it into the dehydrator.
I bet there's still unstirred
in stuff at the bottom.
Yeah, so...
Okay. Yeah.
Some of it didn't dissolve all the way.
>> That's odd.
All right.
We're still going to see
what it tastes like.
So it's probably good that we
don't have quite enough water.
I refuse to drink
Starbucks coffee without the--
Sippy cup lid?
That's what makes it taste good.
For science?
For science!
[Music]
That has almost
no flavor at all,
and I bet it's
because there's still
some pieces in here that haven't
completely dissolved yet.
It tastes like salty milk.
Salty milk.
There you go.
Dehydrated Starbucks latte,
and reconstitute it,
and you get salty milk.
Can we blend that?
Let's see if we can make
this a little bit better.
Oh!
That looks like mud.
Look at that.
I drinked that?
There's a lot
that has not mixed in it all.
Gross!
[Music]
You're the one
who gets to drink it,
so you tell me when you
think it's mixed enough.
More.
It smells a little better now.
Foam on it.
No.
No!
I don't know what that is,
but it's an abomination.
All right, so at least
got the foam off.
Let's do one more--
One more try.
[Music]
Describe the terribleness.
Take some milk,
warm it up slightly,
add like a tablespoon of salt,
leave it out on the counter
for a few hours,
and then add like half
a shot of espresso.
That's what I just drank.
So you're saying
it's pretty bad.
I regret everything.
Guys, don't dehydrate Starbucks.
But if you do dehydrate Starbucks,
don't try and reconstitute the Starbucks.
One of the most popular
projects we have ever had
on our channel to showing
how to build a laser blowgun,
and we have turned that
into a kit that you can order,
and if you act quickly,
you can still get it
in time for Christmas.
That kit comes with everything
you could possibly need.
We have got a glue gun,
PVC pipes, decals, a laser,
everything that you need for
your own backyard adventures.
So my initial reaction,
the second that we open
those kits was just
how much we provided for you.
It's nearly everything
that you need,
and its amazing quality.
It's really fun.
We didn't help plan this out.
So when we opened it,
it really was just
like us getting the kit
for the first time.
I was especially impressed
that it comes like with a glue
gun and glue sticks and stuff.
I was not expecting that.
Everything you need,
it takes probably, what?
15 to 30 minutes depending
how quickly were working to get
your blow gun up and ready,
and then maybe
a little bit longer
if you're trying
to fine-tune the laser,
which it even comes
with everything for that.
Like to zero in that laser.
So it's perfectly accurate.
It worked crazy well.
I also really like the fact that
although it comes
with the supplies
and equipment to make
the nail darts,
with like the paper cone
at the back,
it's like the perfect size
that you can use
miniature marshmallows,
and so you can have
like a laser assisted
marshmallow blow gun fight.
Or blowgun marshmallow wars
in your kitchen or studio.
There might still be
marshmallows all over the place.
Possible.
Just maybe.
We've got a couple
hundred in stock,
but we do expect
them to go fast.
So if you want for yourself,
for a friend or family member,
now is the time to get it.
If you guys decide to go all out
and bedazzle one
of these things,
or just make it look really
really cool, we want to see.
Send us pictures.
There's lots of ways
you can decorate.
You can use paint.
You can use tape.
I guess, you could
use a bedazzler
if you really want gems,
and rhinestones.
>> What is a bedazzlers?
It puts like rhinestones on it.
I don't know
if it works on PVC,
but someone should figure out
how to make that work.
Anyway, lots of ways to make
this blowgun your own,
modifying what we
have in the kit,
very cool stuff.
The link for one of these kits
is in the description.
Have fun.
Be safe.
Build something cool.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video.
The box of the bottom
will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Don't forget to hit
this bomb to subscribe,
and hit that bell
so you never miss out on the fun.
We'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.